[Música]
hace diez años en eeuu el entonces
presidente barack obama promulgó la ley
de protección al paciente y atención
médica asequible más conocida como el
obamacare la política distintiva el
presidente demócrata anunció una
revolución en la unión americana al
expandir la cobertura de atención médica
accesible a un número sin precedentes de
estadounidenses desde entonces su
popularidad ha crecido con el apoyo en
aumento a medida que avanza la pandemia
de kobe 19 pero durante la última década
los republicanos han intentado
repetidamente derogar dicha ley llevando
su batalla hasta la corte suprema
nuestros reporteros en eeuu nos llevaron
hace 10 años atrás con este boleto de
vuelta del obamacare
[Música]
son las 5 de la mañana el día aún no ha
terminado pero docenas de vehículos
hacen fila uno tras otro
dina llegó muy temprano para asegurarse
de ver a un médico
realmente tenemos una cita o es el claro
que llegue si tienes una cita habrán
bueno
estamos en un pequeño pueblo rural de
nevada este instituto se ha convertido
en un hospital de campaña de corta
duración cientos de personas acuden aquí
para recibir atención médica gratuita
545 ha tenido fiebre en los últimos días
una tos que está empeorando pero tengo
alergias
adentro encontramos a dina llegó a
cuatro horas esperando para ver a un
psicólogo su primera visita en años
jain a mi seguro se volvió demasiado
caro cuando tuve que renovarlo con como
lo llaman obamacare
mi póliza casi duplicó su precio en un
año y no podía permitirme así que no
tuve seas este año
un poco más adelante el gimnasio se
transforma en un gigantesco consultorio
dental marc condujo siete horas desde
arizona pasó la noche en su vehículo
después de su consulta este veterano
apenas puede hablar los dentistas
voluntarios le quitaron seis dientes
de phoenix
hoy en día en la primera potencia
mundial 45 mil personas mueren cada año
por falta de atención médica
a menudo tienen un seguro médico pero se
enfrentan a un gasto inesperado y se ven
obligados a elegir entre pagar sus
facturas pagar su préstamo y pagar la
atención dental ahí es donde podemos
ayudar
esta clínica de caridad trata 500
pacientes al día angustia médica que
pensamos que desaparecería con el
obamacare 10 años después de que se
promulgó la ley 40 millones de
estadounidenses siguen sin seguro médico
cómo se llegó a esto
y son 60 los no son 39 la ley de
asistencia asequible acá ha sido
aprobada
el 23 de marzo de 2010 el presidente
barack obama firma la ley de asistencia
asequible conocido como el obamacare
esto es la reforma más ambiciosa en la
historia del sistema de salud americano
hoy después de un siglo de esfuerzo hoy
después de un año de debate hoy después
de reunir todos los votos la reforma de
la atención de la salud se está
convirtiendo en ley en estados unidos
[Aplausos]
pero contrariamente a la creencia
popular el obamacare no es un plan de
salud pública sino una solución privada
el resultado de muchos compromisos con
las compañías de seguros por ley todos
los estadounidenses están obligados a
comprar un seguro o enfrentar una multa
esto se llama la orden individual por
otro lado las empresas deben asegurar a
todos los ciudadanos incluso a los que
tienen un historial médico extenso una
pequeña revolución que permite que más
de 20 millones de estadounidenses se
beneficien de la cobertura médica
[Música]
[Aplausos]
steven era un joven muy activo era el
capitán de su equipo de natación su vida
cambió hace cinco años después de un
análisis de sangre rutinaria
[Música]
estaba en la universidad cuando recibí
la llamada fue la enfermedad de la
clínica se veía aterrada y dijo tienes
altos niveles de glóbulos blancos
y supe de inmediato que significaba
cáncer fue insoportable
los médicos le diagnosticaron una forma
agresiva de leucemia tenía sólo 30 años
mi médico me dijo muy casualmente que mi
medicina iba a costar unos 166 mil
dólares al año
pensé que tenía toda la vida por delante
pero esa cantidad lo echó todo a perder
gracias al obama care el tratamiento de
steven está totalmente cubierto
son todas las drogas que tengo que tomar
cada día para mantenerme vivo un
inhalador y antidepresivos mi quimio fit
m&f en huancané la ley garantiza un
seguro médico asequible para los 50
millones de estadounidenses con
enfermedades crónicas como el cáncer la
diabetes la presión arterial alta o los
problemas cardíacos esto
inextricablemente ligado por esta ley
gracias a esta ley puedo conseguir este
medicamento si no fuera por esta ley el
seguro que la acompaña entonces ya no
estaría aquí como steven la mayoría de
los californianos tienen acceso a un
seguro médico subsidiado pero en eeuu el
acceso a la atención médica sigue siendo
una realidad muy diferente dependiendo
de los 50 estados
porque los últimos 10 años los
republicanos han estado haciendo
cruzadas contra el obamacare
[Aplausos]
d
han intentado revocar la ley no menos de
70 veces en el congreso y tan pronto
como fue elegido donald trump hizo de
ellos su prioridad nunca dejaremos que
el socialismo destruya el sistema de
salud estadounidense su estrategia
desentrañar el obamacare de sus
artículos básicos primero levantando la
obligación de cada estado de extender el
medicaid el programa de ayuda pública
para los más pobres
luego en 2017 el congreso anula el
mandato individual y por lo tanto la
obligación de contratar un seguro es no
se equivoquen esto es en efecto una
derogación y reemplazo de los vamos a
que como resultado del obamacare se ha
vaciado de sus stands
[Aplausos]
[Música]
texas al igual que otros tres estados
republicanos se niega a aplicar todas
las disposiciones de la ley hace tres
años destiny se enfermó
[Música]
cuando tenía 30 años contrajo un virus
intestinal y desde entonces todo ha
cambiado
me recupere del virus pero aparecieron
nuestros síntomas en youtube wow
los médicos le han diagnosticado una
enfermedad genética incurable que
requiere un tratamiento complejo
y aquí están todas las ciudades y
pruebas que pudiera hacer en luisiana y
que no tuve que pagar
todo fue cubierto por el medicaid que
también ha permitido ampliar el programa
medicaid que ofrece cobertura médica a
las personas de bajos ingresos al igual
que destinó otros 15 millones de
estadounidenses han podido beneficiarse
de esta ayuda pública
cuando me enferme pude ir inmediatamente
a buscar yo también
pero gradualmente su condición se
deterioró y destino y perdió su
autonomía hace un año se mudó a texas
para estar más cerca de su familia
desde entonces su vida se ha convertido
en un infiel con texas se niega a
aplicar el lugar bakker ya extender el
programa de medicaid como ilusión
fin
encuentro realmente trágico y abrumador
que alguien tenga que pasar por esto
sting y perdió su cobertura médica sus
tratamientos y medicinas le cuestan
ahora entre 590 y varios miles de
dólares
h
[Música]
tengo que elegir qué especiales ya puedo
ver con nuestra vida mi vida está en
suspenso hasta que consiga la ayuda
[Música]
el caso de destiny está lejos de estar
aislado texas es ahora el estado de eeuu
con más gente sin seguro médico
los republicanos quieren volver a un
sistema completamente privado robert jan
aquí es uno de los abogados detrás de la
demanda de dallas contra el obamacare
que dictaminó que los requisitos del
seguro eran ilegales
de los creadores de la ley de cuidado de
salud asequible crearon el mandato
individual con la idea de que al forzar
a todos a comprar un seguro de salud
proveería los ingresos para compensar el
precio de obama care pero es un concepto
que es inconstitucional porque el
gobierno federal no puede forzar a la
gente a comprar algo que no quiere
watt
en respuesta del fiscal de california
decidió intervenir y llevar esta
decisión judicial ante los nueve jueces
de la corte suprema de eeuu a la demanda
llamada california versus texas refleja
la división ideológica del país
aunque la corte suprema- termine
declarando inconstitucional la organizar
el resto de la ley la protección de los
estadounidenses con enfermedades
crónicas a la protección de los ancianos
y exista protección de los jóvenes todas
estas disposiciones deben mantenerse en
eeuu está empezando a entender que la
salud es un derecho y si no creo que
muchos estadounidenses especialmente en
medio de la pandemia actual quieran
perder el acceso a la atención médica
para sus hijos la pandemia de
coronavirus ha golpeado duramente a la
principal potencia mundial con 260 mil
muertes y más de 12,5 millones de
estadounidenses contagiados pero en los
estados republicanos donde el obamacare
es limitado el tratamiento sigue siendo
una vía de escape
frank de oro se salvó por poco este
hombre de 32 años fue hospitalizado aquí
durante 5 días empecé a toser y estaba
tosiendo sangre síntomas de la neumonía
asociada a kobe 19 pero me di cuenta
cuando llegué al hospital
la ironía de esta historia
frank es un vendedor de seguros pero
empleador no le brinda la cobertura
media y para ahorrar dinero había
elegido no suscribirse al obama con
todos estos documentos corresponden al
tratamiento que recibía en ese hospital
oxígeno medicación cualquier cosa para
combatir el cob y 19
y cuánto fue el costo final alrededor de
24.000 dólares
una carga que probablemente pagará por
el resto de sus francos estaba
particularmente en riesgo es diabético y
tiene problemas de corazón todos los
días tiene que tomar una docena de
medicamentos sin seguro frank recibe sus
tratamientos en esta clínica de caridad
para recoger algunos medicamentos y aquí
los precios de la atención y los
medicamentos dependen de los ingresos de
cada paciente
uno de estos medicamentos es para mi
diabetes sin seguro cuesta entre 475 y
1.200 dólares y cuando viene aquí en
cuanto le sale creo que por esto estoy
pagando 18 dólares
sin la regulación gubernamental los
precios de los medicamentos han
aumentado en un 30% en 10 años siempre
tienes que pagar una cuota de
participación en cada visita y un
deducible que va aumentando así que las
clínicas como la nuestra siempre serán
necesarias porque aunque tengas un buen
seguro tu deducible puede llegar a 11
mil 900 dólares para compensar los
costos adicionales del obamacare las
compañías de seguro han aumentado sus
deducibles hasta 14 mil dólares al año
para una familia de cuatro en eeuu el
cuidado de la salud sigue siendo un
negocio muy lucrativo
y los pacientes a menudo me preguntan
cómo es que con esta compañía de seguro
es mi medicamento me costó tanto y ahora
con esta nueva compañía cuesta tanto y
digo que depende de las negociaciones
que su compañía de seguros tiene con la
industria farmacéutica así que si no nos
gusta pensar así pero aquí la atención
médica es un negocio
[Música]
wow
el obamacare cambió la vida de millones
de estadounidenses como steven la corte
suprema tiene que decidir su destino
[Música]
somos un país que abandona a sus
ciudadanos no somos el país más rico del
mundo y la gente tiene garantizado el
derecho a vivir
aire simple en mi lado de este debate
sobre vivo y en el otro lado no conozco
el valor de esta ley esta ley me salvó
la vida
[Música]
el obamacare está ahora en libertad
condicional y 40 millones de
estadounidenses como frank siguen sin
seguro en medio de la pandemia pero con
la elección de joe biden hay una
renovada esperanza de crear una
cobertura pública para que 10 años
después los demócratas puedan finalmente
cumplir su promesa proveer un seguro de
salud accesible para todos
[Música]
hasta aquí este boleto de vuelta
recuerde que se le gustó este reportaje
puede verlo nuevamente a través de
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima